TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
And for those paying
attention, last week
was Google I/O. So here's
a roundup of everything
that went down at the
developer festival,
starting with everything
that happened at the festival
outside the session rooms.
Check out this playlist
to come along with me
as we explore the venue,
play with all the cool stuff,
and get the inside
scoop from the experts.
Android is officially supporting
the Kotlin programming language
in addition to the
Java language and C++.
Kotlin is a brilliantly
designed, mature,
production-ready
language that we
believe will make Android
development faster and more
fun.
Details, code, and links
are on the post linked
in the description below.
Android Instant
Apps is a new way
to run Android apps without
requiring installation.
Now anyone can build and
publish an instant app.
Android Studio 3.0
Canary is our new preview
that includes three major
features to accelerate
development flow--
a new suite of app
performance profiling tools
to quickly diagnose performance
issues, support for the Kotlin
programming language,
and increased Gradle
build speeds for
large-sized app projects.
There are several
powerful new features
and reports in the Play Console
to help you improve your app's
performance, manage
releases with confidence,
reach a global audience,
and grow your business.
We're excited to announce that
our second generation Tensor
Processing Units are coming to
Google Compute Engine as Cloud
TPUs, where you can connect
them to virtual machines
of all shapes and sizes,
and mix and match them
with other types of
hardware, including
Skylake CPUs and Nvidia GPUs.
You can program these
Cloud TPUs with TensorFlow,
the most popular
open source machine
learning framework on GitHub.
And we're introducing
high-level APIs,
which will make it easier
to train machine learning
models on CPUs, GPUs, or Cloud
TPUs with minimal code changes.
Many top researchers
don't have access
to anywhere near as much
compute power as they need.
To help as many
of them as we can
and further accelerate the
pace of open machine learning
research, we'll make
1,000 Cloud TPUs
available at no cost to ML
researchers via the TensorFlow
research cloud.
With Firebase, we're
providing more insights
to understand app performance
through a new product--
Firebase Performance Monitoring.
We're also introducing
integration between hosting
and cloud functions, adding
support for phone number
authentication, and
improving analytics.
Oh, and we've also started
open sourcing our SDKs.
Through Google Assistant, we
launched the Actions Console,
a new developer console that
helps developers work as a team
and collect data on app usage,
performance, and user discovery
patterns.
This new console is integrated
with the Firebase and Google
Cloud consoles.
To help you take advantage of
the new features of Android
Wear 2.0, we have released a
suite of complication API tools
to make it easier for
you to add complication
support to your watch faces
and a new Wear UI library
to help you build
watch-friendly user interfaces.
We released Developer
Preview 4 Android Things,
which brings new supported
hardware, features,
and bug fixes to the platform.
We've introduced new
innovations for you
to make it easy for your
users to pay for services
with the Google Payment API,
to build profitable businesses
with the completely
redesigned AdMob,
and to grow a user base with
Universal App campaigns.
Screenshots and links are on
the post in the description
below, which is where
you'll find links
to all of the updates
we just reviewed.
Please like and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thank you for tuning in
for this week's round
up of Google I/O. If
you'd like to catch
some of our previous dev show
episodes, they're right here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]